hi i'm christopher hein and today we're
talking about
the edemi position and the sacrifice of
sultan muwari when we're making idimi
so ideally in aikido if we can't make
distance and they're coming in towards
us
as we make a wasa we want to achieve
edemi
however eating is really really hard to
achieve
the reason for this is because every
time we try to get behind someone
then someone's going to be stopping that
eating meat basically just means to get
behind someone to enter in behind them
so every time we try to achieve that
eating they're going to try to stop us
so if we always just fight for the edemi
and they're faster than us of course
we're going to lose
so we can use a trick with sotomowari
that kind of gives us the trade-off and
if you look at aikido forms you'll see
that a lot of the forms talk about
the side-by-side position which is
basically the position you get from a
sultan moare
so i think a lot of times what it's
saying is if you couldn't achieve the
perfect edemi here
here are some things you could do from
the sota mori and have the sutta more is
kind of a
a way to not get a horrible position but
also
sacrifice having to get the best
position right so meaning if they're
faster than us
we can't get that best position so today
we're going to talk about that i'm going
to get josh over here we're going to
work for you
josh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so we're going to talk about
the sacrifice
of the sultan mori position which is
hitoami so
this side by side position and how we
can achieve this position while trying
to get an edemi with the sotomowari
in order to to not get the worst
position possible right a consolation if
you will
okay so if we were here like this if i
was this way with josh
and uh what i would want to be is the
edm right so
that's my number one goal and that's
because this is just a way better
position for me to be in
it's easier for me to escape from here
easier for me to attack from here easier
for me to defend from here everything
for me is easier everything's more
difficult for this guy
so this is the position i want to
achieve now
if i'm trying to get to josh's back he
can counter that by coming this way
right so look i'm trying to get to his
back
he's kind of right and we're going slow
right now but if we were real fast that
same thing would happen
also if josh was faster than me and i'm
trying to get to his back
and josh doing this josh is going to get
to my back right so if this guy's a lot
faster than i am
then i i can't i can't manage this uh
contest
right so i don't want to contest with
this guy what i'll do is i'll make a
a a a concession okay so as
i'm going in and i can tell it's
impossible to get edemi
i will do uh eating me ten con a two
step right so i'm coming in like this as
he's going to my back
i'm gonna fall out like this okay now
see i got this heat though i mean now
hito means not nearly as good as the
eating me position
however when he's trying to counter what
i'm doing i can a lot of times work in a
quicker position to get heat on me
instead of eating me
right so and the reason this is is
because i'm turning around a smaller
axis right
so look if i'm trying to shoot in here
to him and he's trying to shoot opposite
and he's faster than me he's going to
beat me every time to that so what i do
is i turn it around a really tight axis
here and so by doing that let's see if i
can get it
come right here for me all right so what
i'm going to do actually this is going
to be the wrong direction today what i'm
going to do now it's my fault
so what what i'm going to do here is as
i'm coming in he's trying to get to my
back i'm going to turn
real tight around the spot and you can
see this gives me heat to me
now hitomi isn't the best position
however it's better than a honmi
and way better than muhammad right so
the worst place i want to be is here
this guy's stronger than me he's going
to beat me here every time hanumi gives
me a slight advantage
but not the biggest advantage and hitomi
is a little bit better yet right so
anything side by side now if i get edemi
like this
i'm winning so what i want to do is if i
feel the
intestine on that line is i'm going to
turn right here
and that's why the two steps so
important in aikida right so
eating me ten con is this so that in
turn it's in a yumiyashi step and a ten
con like this
that step so important because it can
save us when we can't quite get to edemi
so i can
turn a uh eating me into a hitomi with
sophomore
if i'm losing the edemi so one more time
i'm trying
behind this guy and so i turn right here
and that gets me side by side from where
i want to be one more time on this side
so we're here like this i'm trying to
get back there and he's contesting me i
come out like this
boom and i get right where i want to be
puts me in a good position so i can i
can make a consolation for myself with
that sultan warren
and get heat to me instead of eating me
if i'm being contested on the eating me
here's how to turn eating me into hitomi
with a silta mori i'm chris fryne thanks
for watching